hey everybody welcome to another episode
of Rissa fury i'm kelsey cook and today
i'm joined by such an amazing comedian
so we are so excited have on preacher
lawson he's so sweet hey how you doing
this is a sweet as it gets though and
then it's [ __ ] okay don't talking smack
to me that'd be worse we lose oh I did
it already have you lost with this show
no never you also have never had a black
guy so time to lose
yeah it's going down I should be on that
side that's a really shirt I match
little guys on here come on man
well Conda we could be killing right no
I'm sorry
I'm ready to do this you have no idea
she won't even know I got a food while
telling my house I wake up like this
this I wake up every day every morning
I'm like yah yah let's go
I'm ready kiss Wow let's do this you
said like black people good at foosball
play foosball table no no we're not good
but we fast I did this we're not good at
food black we don't say food we'll play
basketball you'll play basketball I
think I win I feel like I had probably
what I would I take you it like Pig like
when I went I'll [ __ ] I'll die
against you but Pig I used to be my
team's three-point like designated
shooter okay okay cool you have a black
hood on playtest but might win but you
have one in your do which was I just
randomly was like I love preacher
preacher do we still fun to have on the
show I had no idea you had a table in
your house yeah but I do have one but
it's like it's just it's like a mini one
this is serious yeah this is nice these
are almost the size of grown men yeah
I'm super excited to play you know
spinning you know that you all know
spinning like none of this none of that
Wow well what do I do this
so average so what so I got it so this
is it that's it this is it
that's it all right and you're strong
dude like your Instagram is full of just
like you ripped oh I have faith in you
that you'll record
yeah I yeah the record how fast I took
my shirt off yeah I haven't ate all day
just over there for that you know I'm
gonna get some snack stops fast and if
we're gonna play all right the first
game pretty standard just a game two
five so I'm gonna let you start at the
ball first
you let me shower the ball first lady's
[Music]
legs yes I told that when I told you it
is over I wish this the walls like if I
was like I'm saying climb this wall
right now but it's decoration I'm a
certain to dinner I got asthma
all right is it my turn take your point
[ __ ] okay well you gotta call me
at what you can't just say take you now
I have a name you angered the beat Oh
what's happening you ready oh we think
cuz I want to make it gay I'm saying
let's go
was it this night every time you okay
you know what no one likes you kiss me
you ever notice that I'm just being
honest I'm just being honest what's with
the comedy scene talks about Kelsey no
spin my bad okay
Oh Oh my bad spin again okay I know it's
a hard habit to break
yeah it is super hard
you know what I just loved watching from
where you were first point so there's no
but that's because this is different
like if I was on the black side you know
I mean do you want a switch for a point
you know what I'm gonna let you I just
want you to have an edge so go ahead and
okay oh my bad my bad Smith it again
because I once already
oh my god what's gonna happen what oh my
best man I keep spinning it but I'm just
I can't I can't get in there right now
get in now okay all right I know you
drank one away because I spent it if I
didn't spend it you know usually we try
to have like you know light funny banter
on the show but I just feel like she
didn't do a countdown do we do the
countdown
we're supposed to countdown all right so
did I lose room the first game badly
that's the reason I wouldn't playing for
real because I thought the first time
you score Bennis yeah that's it so what
now yeah I just use all my energy if I
didn't if I don't jump in there I
thought to take it I can just say how
good it feels to just be this like tiny
girl who just like kicked the [ __ ] like
the strongest strongest buffers do you
all know anybody that works out there
I'm the stronger dude I am NOT buff I'm
in shape
I think I'm insane
[Music]
all right so we're gonna pick some
things that's going to make it easier
for you to baby you can score an either
goal and you'll get a point so you can
go backward forward either way if you
score in a goal you get a point my
handicap is that I have to score two
goals in 20 seconds and if I don't I
have to play the rest of match
blindfolded little big easier you think
okay like a score any goal you can score
any any in either goal I have to score
two points in 20 seconds or else I have
to play the rest much blindfolded you
get it all first I get the ball first
all right but you can't just [ __ ] around
with it for 20 seconds oh you're right
you're right you're right you're right
don't you do it no I'm not doing
anything come on man this Dollar Tree
max over here it made me fall this made
me fall and she knew that that's what
she did include aside she did include my
side come on man celebrate come on
that's on you I hey we're still playing
though got these Family Dollar mats
what's up man come on man you're so
cheap wait you got a point I've got two
points you still get a score in either
goal bodies on how to play blindfold on
oh right that's not that's cheating Oh
cuz I was celebrating that's on you know
in football will you score they
celebrate and give a little ball
spinning thing they like yeah we just
scored and then you reset this is
foosball it's football
it's the same letter mm-hmm they just
added they switched the letters up oh my
god that's a choice you made okay that's
on you okay oh you don't mess up I get a
score here yep yep so you take a point
win by I know but there was stuff
together you gonna be mad at me because
they stuck together I'm not doing I
didn't do that
oh man I feel like our friendship is
just quickly okay oh you three one way
conquer huh what you born this way
anyway going in the go that's all good
okay this is like intense cuz now I have
to play defense on both sides we've
never done this before cuz you might go
forward or backward oh yes I'm gonna go
back that's not about it that was go
back again damn it oh my bad
see they keep sticking what do eyes are
so sticky won't even doughnuts so hey
what are you talking about what's that
what did you place in a what did you
place it on America's Got Talent
oh yeah put that back on make sure you
have oh I just want counting I please
are you trying to show out that I lost
my face that lost to a 12 year old I'm
feel like you doing I'm just making
conversation
yeah I wouldn't uh I was in the I was
top 10 the first time okay I got top 5
the second time that's amazing that's
truly amazing what year was the first
time you played all right you first time
you did oh thank God for you got 10 we
got 500 point what I have one more point
I don't even take it seriously man
that's the only reason I lost
so we're gonna play two ball that means
that we each start with a ball and to
get a point you have to score both balls
if I scrub all you are ball it's a wash
yep square both and it's just two three
RJ Berger we're gonna go to five let's
go to fight this time because I'm
beating you so fast so we went I really
was not a good person I didn't realize
this so if I beat you then it'll be the
second girl you've lost you with this na
GT right oh wait it's okay we'll just
play fair
alright let's go let's do I let you in
this point because I started unfairly
how about a spin what point spin like on
this ball just moon out the same I think
I'm ready I'm not playing
when we do it moving my hand you know
what I did that I did that
oh so you're welcome thank you so much
yeah anytime you need me score for you
I'm gonna give you both of these balls
for this one since I started illegally
the first to come off for me already yep
your two balls on the table I forgot to
tell you preacher that when you lose
because you're [ __ ] you're the host of
world's most amazing dog yeah on
Facebook watch yep but your penalty for
losing is that you have to eat a dog
treat
I can't even though I'm a vegan yeah
cuz vegan baby see it works out everyone
calls us losers but when it comes to
losing wow that is not a suck to [ __ ] we
have to think of something wait how
about my punishment is you playing
blindfold that makes literally no sense
but you just feel like sorry
dumb now okay this is the host of the
show she's called me come on yeah well
this games still not over you know aha
so on she's blind for yourself right now
right now okay alright we don't do one
ball to right just one ball alright
alright
and you rate a rope yeah let's do it I
felt an arm
I think there's cheese there's cheating
involves I do it again ready 1 2 3 oh
you're going down girl
you're going down hey oh here we go here
we go wait how do you know it's here you
you're such a cheater yeah blindfolded
you can hear it and I can hear where you
are now it's all on the table it is on
table yes okay I can't do this hey hey
you know what
that was a good punishment for me so
yeah I agree
hey you know what it's okay it's okay
everybody can't be this good and you
know what I'll started no show it's
gonna be preaching Lawson foosball and
I'm gonna teach y'all some new
Trix listen losers can't talk okay in a
way oh my god Isis fried by the way
anyway I'm gonna start a new YouTube
channel
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we're just gonna do one last point
just put it on on on three okay there we
go three all right hold on are you
serious you know what you get you got a
cheat to win that's what you get
cheater when I have my blindfold on you
must have been like picking it up and
just throwing it because I felt human
arms on my men all might've brushed it a
little bit throwing it in that Adam grab
that grabbing well technically I didn't
cheat because we're not trying to cheat
it didn't go in so so hard like the last
time I moved it with my hands it was
stuck and did I what I did the times I
cheated cheated it didn't work
technically I'm a cheater but it didn't
I wasn't I didn't I wasn't successful
you know me that's like the worst kind
of person I know
listen you got one pretty good
you're pretty good I'm not gonna lie
you're my one of my toughest challenges
but thank you I mean when you when I
come back you know maybe you'll be
better I want you to come back you're so
much fun to play thank you I appreciate
it
where people can find you a preacher you
can find me a preacher lost on Twitter
and my facebook snapchat you to timbered
tinder bumble black tea to me you can
find me yeah on yeah on all those social
medias every lost them the only preacher
lost creatures so [ __ ] funny thank
you there's a reason he's been in the
finals twice mmm air he's got now like
he's truly a beast and I won't cheat on
anything else the only thing I speak is
so funny please go follow him my
Instagram is at kausika comedy twitter
is at Kelsey cook
Kelsey cook calm for tour dates and
subscribe to self publish podcast and to
Securi keep watching these episodes and
we'll see you guys next time thank you
guys for watching another episode of
Rissa fury be sure to pick up your
official Larisa fury shirt their buttery
soft they feel like dolphin skin they're
amazing
be sure to LIKE and subscribe to the all
things comedy channel and you can get
the shirts at the link below free
shipping